تضمن رد حماس الموافقه على اطار اتفاق
يرمي الى تطبيق هدنه تامه ومستدام على
ثلاث مراحل وتستغرق كل مرحله منها 45 يوما
وتشمل التوافق على تبادل الاسرى والثمين
وانهاء الحصار واعاده اعمار القطاع وطالبت
حماس بالانتهاء من مباحثات التهدئه التامه
قبل بدء المرحله الثانيه وضمان خروج
القوات الاسرائيليه من حدود القطاع وبدء
عمليه الاعمار ووفقا للمقترح فقد عرضت
حماس في المرحله الاولى اطلاق سراح
المحتجزين الاسرائيليين من النساء
والاطفال والمسنين والمرضى مقابل 1500
اسير فلسطيني بينهم 500 من اصحاب الاحكام
المؤبده والاحكام العاليه كما اشترطت حماس
ادخال ما لا يقل عن 500 شاحنه يوميا من
المساعدات والوقود الى القطاع خلال
المرحله الاولى وطالبت ايضا بعوده
النازحين الى اماكن سكنهم وضمان حريه
حركتهم وفتح المعابر كما تضمن رد حماس
ضروره الموافقه على ادخال ما لا يقل عن 60
الف مسكن مؤقت و 200 ال خيمه ايواء خلال
المرحله الاولى واشترطت اقرار خطه اعمار
المنازل والمنشات الاقتصاديه والمرافق
العامه المدمره خلال مده لا تتجاوز ثلاث
سنوات كذلك اشتمل الرد وقف اقتحام
المستوطنين للاقصى وعوده الاوضاع في
المسجد الى اوضاع ما قبل عام 2002 وطالبت
حماس ايضا ان تكون كل من قطر ومصر
والولايات المتحده وتركيا وروسيا والامم
المتحده اطرافا ضامنه لتنفيذ هذا
الاتفاق